hi guys today we're going to talk about
why people fail with intermittent
fasting okay well number one they never
start minimun fasting brings up a mental
problem because you're depriving someone
of food and two people food is survival
so you're taking away their ability to
survive but what you have to realize is
you're not really doing that you're just
switching the food fuel for the fad feel
you're finally for once living on your
own fat you're living off of the food
that you ate months ago maybe years ago
I've turned into fat you're finally
using it as fuel so once you realize
that maybe you'll feel a little bit
better about that because you're not
really depriving yourself you're just
burning up stored reserves and people
have a lot to burn so you can drink
coffee that won't break your fast you
can do tea that won't break your fast
the key is making sure that when you eat
the the meal is very healthy okay and
and it's big you don't want to cut
calories yes you make cut calories just
from the nature of eating less frequent
but ideally you want to eat a
nutrient-dense meal we call it a healthy
keto so if you're new to my channel
click below for the exact diet you need
to be on ok number two you feel worse
when you do in a minute fasting how
could that be now you're going through a
transition phase it takes two to three
to four up to five days to transition
over because you're building new
machinery new enzymes in the process
it's the vitamin and nutrient like
mineral deficiencies that create these
side-effects so all you have to do
increase your potassium as electrolyte
increase your sodium as sea salt and b1
in the form of nutritional yeast and you
won't have hardly any side effects that
should handle most of them so in the
document below that you can download I
show you very gradually how to go into
this so you don't feel worse ok but I
understand if you feel where
you may want to stop it just means that
you're not doing it correctly number
three you're not losing weight now the
vast majority of people that start in a
minute fasting start losing weight and a
lot of weight
some people might lose her a while and
then they Plateau other people may not
lose initially for this one simple
reason and it's based on a principle
that I have in my book which is this you
get healthy to lose weight not lose
weight to get healthy it sounds really
simple but it's very powerful and what
do I mean by getting healthy I mean
repair damaged organs your body
especially if you're menopausal if you
have atrophy will focus on repair before
just fat burning okay so what you want
to do is you want to look at other
positive health factors is your energy
going up is your cravings going away are
you less hungry you have better
cognitive function that means it's
working if you want to improve the
weight loss you cut your carbs when you
eat you do longer fasting and you add
exercise and more sleep
- alright number four this is a biggie
other people your so-called friends and
family members are discouraging you
they're telling you oh my gosh you're
starving your body you need to be eating
every three hours you need to eat a
breakfast that is absolutely not true we
don't need to eat that frequently if we
eat that frequently we never tap into
our fat reserves how you gonna burn fat
if you're eating so frequently eating
very frequently gets you into a massive
trouble with insulin okay and this is
why we have a massive problem with
diabetes and pre-diabetes so you're not
starving your body you're just shifting
what fuel you are running off of you're
fat if you want to burn fat fasting is
the best way to do it and also if we
look at the when versus to what like
what's more important when you eat or
what you eat believe it or not when you
eat is a little bit more important than
what you eat I don't want that to be the
reason you eat what you want
but the point is that intermittent
fasting is slightly more important than
what you eat because if you actually do
a keto plan and eat frequently you will
still trigger insulin just by the nature
of eating in general
okay so insulin is triggered by carbs
and frequent eating so that's why in a
minute fasting with healthy Kido goes
together why because we're trying to
heal insulin and insulin is behind most
chronic health problems then we get into
what's called the five and two and
alternate day fasting what is that I
don't even consider these intermittent
fasting five and two is basically eat
what you want five days out of the week
and then two days you cut your calories
down to 500 per day well that's not
fasting you're still eating it's a low
calorie diet it's not intermittent
fasting plus you're eating what you want
five days out of the week so that is a
very unhealthy pattern of eating okay
alternate day fasting this is where you
pretty much eat what you want every
other day and the days that you
so-called fast you're eating 500
calories again that's not fasting you're
eating 500 calories it's a low calorie
diet there are some benefits okay to do
low calorie but it comes with the
package it doesn't get rid of your
hunger you don't convert over it's hard
to do because you haven't adapted it
takes a period of time to totally adapt
to get rid of hunger and cravings I mean
you can do a low calorie diet with the
cravings but chances are you're gonna go
off because you crave the entire success
of intermittent fasting done correctly
is this your hunger goes away if you
have no hunger okay you can go longer
you won't give up easily okay and this
is what builds willpower is your ability
to say no to food and the essence of why
intermittent fasting works so well is
you can go longer without eating and you
actually build your will
power which destroys your willpower is
going off the program caving in but if
you can control yourself and you are in
the driver's seat over the food you can
strengthen your willpower and that is
very very important the ability to
control your environment to not give in
to the different foods around you I mean
very few people can do that but in a
minute fasting is a tool to get into
that state okay all right depriving
nutrients now not if you actually do a
healthy keto plan when you eat we always
recommend to have a very good large meal
with nutrient-dense foods and I also
recommend adding certain supplements as
well and I have a lot of videos on that
so that way you're never deprived of
nutrients we don't want your hair to
fall out we don't want your nails to
become brittle we don't want you to have
side effects and I show people exactly
what to eat what to take to avoid that
now sometimes you might share this this
concept of intermittent fasting is not
good for women because it destroys their
hormones and you find out they're
actually doing the five and two or the
alternate day fasting they're not doing
it correctly the truth is that
intermittent fasting with healthy
ketosis is extremely healthy for the
endocrine system from my experience
working with thousands of people all
over the world rarely do I ever see any
problems with women doing this I'm
seeing just the opposite I'm seeing
massive improvements with women and
their hormones especially after
menopause we're seeing improved
fertility especially if you're
increasing the healthy fats that you
need which actually is the raw material
for the endocrine system so it can
strengthen your willpower intermittent
fasting is anti-cancer intermittent
fasting helps you create more brain
cells there are massive benefits but if
you don't start and you don't do it
right and you give up because of that or
you don't continue it long-term you're
not going to see the success so click
the document down below
find out how to do in a minute fasting
correctly and it will work for you
thanks for watching
so if you're enjoying this content go
ahead and share it with someone that
could really benefit from it